[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you the people that's
right we help you win in your life
specifically in your money in your work
and in your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me this hour
the phone number to jump in because is
your show America is
8825 5225 that's
[Music]
8825 5225 The Fabulous Jade warshaw
ready to go warmed up did you do voice
exercises in The Green Room there she is
Pitch Perfect as always she'll take your
money questions I'll jump in and then
hey you got some work questions some
mindset stuff hey I'm struggling here uh
I feel like I've got a lid on me
professionally which is affected me
financially any of those work rated
questions I'll take on and Jade wads
weighs in as well so let's go to The Big
Apples where we start Julie is waiting
on us Julie how can we help
today hi guys are you my call yeah you
I'm good um so I'm calling I've been
listening to your podcast like probably
over the last year and then since 2024
I've really been like obsessed with it
and listening to it every single day I
think I need to call it um so I'm
calling because I feel like my husband
and I have the baby steps like all out
all out of order okay we have debt we
have credit card debt we have car
payments we have a mortgage and we have
student loans but I feel like we we have
savings to pay off our credit card debt
but I'm just
nervous that if we pay it off we're
going to like plummet our savings and
then if there is an
emergency yeah it's been hard since we
bought our house to build our savings
back up so I'm just like I like having
that cushion we have like about 30 over
a little over 30,000 in our savings okay
and about 13,000 in credit card debt
okay so I'm like we could just pay that
off right
now yeah but I'm nervous to just like
see it plummet and then we have other
payments too that's right yeah there's
um you know that that emotional feeling
is normal because you're used to seeing
a pile of money in your account you log
in you're used to seeing it and there's
part of that it's giving you a a truly a
false sense of security right because if
you do the math which you don't have to
do much you can do the math and see well
that 30,000 is not actually your 30,000
it belongs to Capital One and the car
company and Sally May or you know navian
or whoever holds your student loan and
you're just keeping it from them that's
not actually your money and so when you
when you put it that way and you start
to realize listen the debt that I owe
that's the real that's the real scary
thing that's the risk that I've created
in my life and until I give them the
money that I owe them they're not going
to stop coming after me and so the real
question then is what's scarier to have
these companies relentlessly coming
after you for money or to just give them
the money that you owe them and get on
with your
life right so right yeah back to your
point of kind of I feel like we're doing
the baby steps out of order that means
you know the right
order and there's there's a reason
that and I I want to take a moment and
explain the reason inse yeah but I think
if understand the reason underneath it
it'll make a lot more sense and this is
for anybody listening it's not just we
don't do it like this cuz it has a nice
ring to it right we do it like this
because it truly does work um so when
you do the first thing you have the
$1,000 of security you know let's debunk
that that is supposed to make you feel a
little bit shaky so if you were to take
that 30,000 and apply it to debt and
only or in this case take 29,000 apply
it to debt and keep a th000 there that
is going to make you feel uncomfortable
and it so I want to validate that
feeling the hope is that you go okay I
can't live like this forever let me
tackle baby step which is paying off all
that debt besides your mortgage and so
that should light kind of a fire
underneath you to like let's keep going
let's go as quickly as possible and the
funny thing is okay so your C your
credit card payments how much do you pay
every month to credit
cards so this month we actually put like
a a large chunk we like threw like six
grand towards it okay okay on okay six
grand how much do you pay towards your
car notes every
month um about a th for both of our cars
okay how much do you pay to work student
loans every
month a thousand okay so that's
$8,000 I don't have any but it's my
husband's but look look what I'm doing
here in three months in three and a half
months you'll have the $330,000 back
once you pay off this debt that's how
quickly you'll resave this money because
all of that money is going out the door
payments but when you have it back
you'll save lightning speed like you'll
you'll save so much faster then you'll
be able to start investing a full
percentage into retirement so there's a
way that this works because the thing is
if you don't pay off this debt it's
going to linger
on right and that's the thing like with
our the interest rate and everything I
feel like yeah we're just wasting money
and you're not going to be able to do
the things that most people say they
want to do I'm sure you want to have um
I'm sure you want to have a nice
retirement I want to I'm sure you if you
have kids you're going to want to sa for
their college you're not going to have
the that's thing too like go ahead when
I mentioned the baby steps are out of
order like we have a retirement for our
daughter we I have a um we have a
college savings for her we have we're
tithing to our church and I'm also like
Is it wise to tith yes when I have debt
yes I know it's more like a spiritual
heart thing but well no yes it is but
it's also a principle of giving when you
give you receive when you have an open
hand money goes out and money comes in
so even if you're not a Christian person
it is a great principle to just live by
so I would continue to tithe um at the
minimum 10 like 10% I would continue to
do that I would pause all other
investing for the time being again the
baby steps it works for a reason because
here's the thing if Let's Pretend let's
say that you say I'm going to keep
investing my money and I'm going to use
this $30,000 though and I'm going to pay
off some of this debt you're already out
of order cuz you're continuing to
investing to invest which means you're
paying off your debt slower which means
it's going to take you longer to get out
of debt and if you happen to have a
major emergency do you want to know what
people do they look at their 401k and
they go oh well maybe I can use that
money as opposed to when you only have
$1,000 saved baby you get what is known
as creative and you start coming up with
ideas and you do everything you can
because you've removed that false safety
net from under you and now it's just you
and your money but when you and when you
do it the right way you're out of debt
you start investing and then your
Investments are actually your
Investments you don't touch them they
stay there they they grow they compound
interests like they're supposed to and
now you're doing things the right way so
there really is um all sorts of
structural components in building this
house the right way Julie how much time
will it take to get out of debt if you
do this you use this 29,000 or whatever
the situation is as Jay's walking you
through this how much when are you gonna
get done if if you use the savings now
to eliminate debt what's your payoff
date well I could pay it like today
credit card I know I
know what about the rest of it my yeah
we still have the other stuff how much
is the other stuff so so how long do you
anticipate it would take you guys are
making large chunks which is good but
we're running out of time just give me a
ballpark okay how long before we pay it
all off if we if we liquidate the
savings I would have to sit down and
like really do the math well we know for
sure you got $88,000 a month so my guess
is you could probably strike that up to
10,000 bucks a mon we about 12 we make
about 12,000 a month okay listen
together so here's the point here's why
I'm asking you you have got to map that
out today like as soon as this call is
done what's the payoff date once we use
most of that 30 and when you get the
picture the vision of how quickly your
life changes and you get ahead like Jay
just laid out this is a no-brainer
there's nothing to be insecure about
this is the ramsy show
[Music]
hey guys Ramsey Solutions started small
and grew fast because of that rapid
growth there were times when our systems
slowed us down that's why we switched to
net site it works for us and it'll help
your business too whether you're
starting on a card table like I did or
you're well on on your way to becoming a
multi-million dollar Company netw Suite
can scale with you and help you
communicate and plan better because you
know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay net Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation more
than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netw Suite today and find
out how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
netsuite's free kpi checklist designed
to give you consistently excellent
performance at netsuite.com Ramsey
that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show thrilled
that you're with us America the phone
number to jump in is8 825 5225 we're
going to talk about your money we'll
talk about your work we'll talk about
your relationships all three of those
areas are intricately connected and when
you're not winning in one we tend to see
that you may not be winning in others
and if you're in a four alarm fire in
any of those areas we're here to help as
well Jade warshaw joins me I'm Ken
Coleman with Ramsey personalities we are
your host today
8825 5225 Julian is up next in New York
City Julian how can we help hi thank you
for taking my
call my question right now I am around
20 years old I am 20 years old in
college and I'm currently making around
20 to $225,000 a month and my boss
wanted to give me a pretty big bonus for
basically hitting a pretty big Benchmark
in in sales around 1.5 million and he
wanted to give me a $50,000 bonus to put
towards any gift he didn't just want to
give it to me cash and he wanted to
essentially help me buy a new car and
I'm 20 I'm in college and realistically
financially it wouldn't make a really
big dent for me to put an extra you know
10 to 20 into a car and potentially get
like a 60 a $70,000 car and I was
wondering if it wasn't you know a stupid
financial decision do you think that
would be potentially a good decision for
me to make you know given that I'm I'm
20 and it wouldn't hurt me financially
you have no debt or any debt at all no
debt nothing 200,000 in savings and
you're making 25 20 to 25 Grand a month
correct and he's gonna put he's going to
give you 50 towards a car and so if you
buy a $50,000 car you don't pay a nickel
if you buy a $70,000 car you paid 20 and
you've already got 200 plus in the bank
am I hearing all this right yes exactly
I know it sounds a little bit crazy but
what's your what's your concern I have a
concern well let's hear his first what's
your why'd you call us to ask us about
this well I was just wondering because I
think that I'm relatively mature for my
age and I guess going back to school I'm
taking a semester off and I'm going back
to school um you know in in in in in
August in the fall and I was just
wondering you know given that I've
worked so hard for the last few years I
feel that I I deserve it and I'm excited
to drive around in a nice car not have
to drive around in the subu but I don't
know I guess other people kind of seeing
that I don't want to look like the kind
of person you like my parents bought me
a really nice car you know what I mean I
understand what you're saying but if I'm
in your shoes I don't give a crap what
anybody thinks about the car I'm driving
especially if it was a gift and if it
were me unless I'm missing something the
guy's going to give you 50,000 towards
if he will not give it to you as a bonus
he's going I'm doing it this way then
the rules are the rules and you're
busting it you're killing it unless I'm
missing something uh but if it were me I
wouldn't get $70,000 car I'd get a
$50,000 car and not pay a nickel I'd
take the free car I wouldn't put any
extra money into that but let me also
say if You' been listen to this program
Dave talks about the ratio Jade can
break that down is when we talk about
ratio to what you make so for you to
spend 20 on top of the 50 based on what
you make and what you've got in the bank
it's a no-brainer so your if your
concern is I'm worried about what others
gonna say because I'm young and I'm
driving a nice car around first of all I
don't give a crap what they think and
secondly you've got a legitimate story
you're not a trust fund baby it's
nothing you to be ashamed of you've
worked really hard to get to this point
where you're making incredible Money
young man you've been Frugal you have no
debt uh man I'd say enjoy this bonus I
have a question though uh I have a
couple questions
um you mentioned going back to school
what does that mean for your income when
you go back to
school well surprisingly I've actually
been able to balance this pretty well
with school okay um I just want to
finish getting the the the degree I
think that it's valuable and my parents
are you know very thankful they pay for
it so you're doing this while in school
correct correct yeah he's making this
money while in school he when you said
going back to school in August it made
it seem like you were gone for a while
or hadn't finished I I may take a bit of
a pay cup but realistically I'll still
be able to make a pretty decent uh a
pretty decent amount uh yeah yeah you're
you're you're crushing it that's crazy
listen you're 20 years old what I want
to know what do you sell what do you can
you tell us yes so I work with
influencers online who have very big
audiences like anywhere from 200,000 to
to a million followers online and I
basically help sell and market products
to those uh to to basically their Their
audience whether it's real estate or uh
make money online coaching anything like
that Fitness
coaching and Market yeah yeah this is a
no-brainer that's excellent this is Nob
brainer get the car hey how much how
much of your own money are are you going
to add with it or are you just going to
take the 50,000 and get a $50,000 car
I'm thinking if I decide to get a car
I'll just get the car I really want and
if that ends up being 70 I'll put an
extra 20 if it ends up being 50
I'll it just be smart that's great who
cares what haters thing they're drinking
on that haterade you worked hard for
this yeah that's fantastic I love that
story you don't get that call very often
so why I ask all the questions want to
make sure I got all the facts but that
one's pretty straightforward way to go
young man all right let's go to uh
Andrea in San Antonio Texas Andrea how
can we help hi thanks for taking my call
sure what's up my husband and I don't
know what we should do regarding a house
we have been trying to sell since last
June that are three builders in the
neighborhood Building Homes and
Apartments there are several streets of
brand new homes for sale the builders
have their own financing companies so on
top of having lowered the prices of the
new homes for sale they are also
offering lower interest rates to
potential buyers we don't think this
scenario will change in 2024 the
expenses for this home total about about
$1,100 per month my husband has been an
employed for seven months now and I just
got a part-time job so with my part-time
job I'm guessing that our income is
going to be about 5,000 a month starting
this month okay so we're n nervous
because we've been digging into our
savings for several months now my
husband is a software engineer so we
thought that he was was going to be able
to find another job quickly but it's
been 7even months and he hasn't found a
job help me understand the timeline a
little bit better and what caused you to
move in the first place so you had this
house and you moved did you move far
away are you in the same state help me
understand a little bit more we are
about 30 minutes from this house we
downsized our kids grew up left joined
the military the house was too big for
us and you bought another house yes both
are paid
for both houses are paid
for yes then why why did you say so the
Thousand the 1100 what is that like
taxes and insurance what's yes okay yes
taxes Insurance um
utilities so how you've got two paid for
homes you're not able to rent
it well that's the issue with the
location it is something like a
dormatory city okay and it has lots of
new homes and the traffic is really bad
to get there uh we only had two
complaints some potential buyers one was
that there was no bathtub in the master
bathroom and the other was the location
they thought was too far and there are
no grocery stores yeah but you said
Builders are in there building around
you right and left that means it's a
good location lower the price do you
have a good real estate
agent um I do one recommended by Dave we
think he's really good it's the second
time we work with him we really don't
think it's the problem is the real
estate agent we think it's the
competition yeah which is why why Ken is
saying lower the price he's not saying
take a like a drastic plummet but go go
little by little until you can really
pinpoint what the value of this property
is let me point out another problem
though because you're telling me the
problem is this and this and that I'm
seeing what bothers let me tell you
what's bothering me about this situation
I see someone with two paid for homes
which I think that's great you you
bought two homes in cash $1,100
shouldn't be breaking your world right
now and I think it's because you guys's
income is so low and I know your
husband's looking for work you guys got
to get that income up that's the biggest
fire that you need to put out right now
because when you're earning the right
amount of money suddenly this $1,100 on
two properties that you own you're going
to start to look at that as a blessing
instead of a burden and right now it's a
burden because your husband is not
working full time yeah this is uh it's
been 7 months I don't know what the
seven months is we running out of time
but you don't need a part-time job you
need two or you need a full-time job uh
until you figure out how to sell this
house you don't need two houses either
so you guys are close but this is just
some hustle right now in a couple
different areas thanks for the call this
is the Ramsey Show we'll be right
[Music]
back
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast preapproval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more welcome back to the Ramsey Show
America thrilled that you are with us
it's where we help you win in your money
and your work and in your relationships
I'm Ken Coleman Jade warshaw joins me
this hour the phone number is 8825 5225
and Jade uh across the studio through
the glass on the debt free stage in the
lobby are some folks and that means
we've got a debt free scream coming your
way uh Gary and Melissa welcome thanks
thanks all right where are you guys from
from Bell Plane Minnesota Point
Minnesota is that near Minneapolis just
South Minneapolis okay good boy are you
just excited to see the sun this time of
year yep there it is all right so uh all
this way to do a debt free scream very
exciting so let's hear the numbers how
much debt did you pay off in how long we
paid off
$165,000 over 47 months all right wow
and what was your range of income we
started about at 160 and ended at about
200 o what uh what led to the uh bump
and pay we just leaned into our career
as we both ear ined promotions and stuck
to it what do you mean by promotions
they were he moved from a um Factory
position to a safety manager and I just
kind of took different roles at my
current company and what are you doing
I'm a client relationship manager okay
fantastic that is awesome all right what
was uh all this debt what did the 165
get comprised of by the time we finally
got down to just writing everything out
um we had a helck that we had been
leaning on we had a car and then we had
a credit card that we were just kind of
paying off every month um so that was
probably the smallest and easiest one to
pay off okay so pretty good size helck
yeah it was about 40,000 some we used it
to remodel our basement and then kind of
kept it and kept it going okay all right
so tell us 47 months ago what happens
what was the catalytic moment to lead
you on this journey yeah so he was going
back to school it was his last semester
and we had found we were kind of we were
trying to cash flow it but we'd get a
little short so we'd pull a little bit
out of the helck we were getting kind of
sloppy and as last semester came up and
the the tuition payment was going to be
doing we finally said this is it um
we're doing it in cash and we had about
2 and a half months before that was due
and we did it and that was kind of our
our biggest Victory as we got started
that's awesome so you're funding
education out of the HELOC a little bit
Yeah cash flowing it but then we were
kind of filling the gaps we were just
being sloppy there was no reason for it
yeah so what was kind of like you hit
the moment of like listen we're not
going to do this anymore we're going to
start paying cash what how did you find
Ramsay like how did you find like this
is and this is the way we're going to do
it going forward yeah we knew about it
before that uh we just weren't following
it we kind of thought we were doing good
on our on our path you know we were kind
of budgeting um but then it was just
like just tired of the revolving debts
like this year it was a hilock a couple
years before it was a 401k loan it just
kind of things we were just it was a
shell game we were just kind of moving
the debt around and just got tiring it
does get tiring so you're working the
baby steps is this you're getting on a
budget is this you guys picking up extra
work or is this like listen we're just
tightening up on the budget we're just
getting very clean on what we're doing
tell us about that yeah it was pretty
much just us um tightening it up as much
as we could cutting out any unnecessary
expenses uh we didn't have any side
hustles but we tried to do more
experience-based activities with the
kids you know we do a lot of camping uh
going up to the cabin stuff like that so
just try to cut out those unnecessary
expenses do you uh do the ice fishing in
Minnesota do you guys do that we do and
I guess Speer fishing is probably yeah I
learned about that I don't want to go
down the rabbit hole for the rest of the
people who don't care but you talked
about camping all that and I heard about
how you do the ice fishing like it's
like a whole thing it's like a a whole
experience everybody goes out and all
that jazz yeah it's fun yeah no I don't
think it is I'll be honest I heard it
described and I didn't think it was fun
at all but uh much much love to you on
that all right so uh let's talk talk
about this what was was there uh was
there a beginning point that you guys
said okay we heard a little bit about
this ramsy stuff now we're going to do
it was it hard or was it we were on the
same page what was the beginning of that
Journey like when you finally said all
right we're committing how I mean was it
hard for you or did you just roll right
through it it was a little bit of
getting on the same page we started with
that first goal of getting that last um
tuition payment and then from there it
was adopting the budget which
um I wrote out the budget I'm the nerd
um took him a little bit to get into the
budget but once we started rolling then
uh we were both fully bought in yeah I
was reluctant at first it was uh yeah
the idea of getting on that budget was a
little rough um but once you saw it
start to really work that's when I
brought bought in all the way so re
relate to that a little bit because I
know a lot of people dislike budgeting
right they hear the word budget they
think it's a punishment they think it's
something that's holding them back uh
what changed that for you because I I
love talking to people who don't like
budgeting and changing their minds so
the one thing that was neat is Melissa
printed out this kind of like detris
Tetris uh um you know like all the
little pieces equal a certain amount of
money and we had that sitting on a
refrigerator and then every time we were
paying off any amounts uh Lissa was
really good at filling in those spaces I
like to fill it in so you like to feel
the Milestone like you want to feel the
Milestone you're celebrating it's kind
of a fun yeah and it was a way to see
that work and we did the same thing with
our house where we printed off a picture
of like balloons holding up our house
and each one was a certain dollar amount
and now wait a minute did you pay the
house off we did what oh you didn't tell
us that second I was digging I was like
165 I was trying to figure out how big
was that credit card listen you paid
your house off wow that's okay okay okay
Mak a little more sense yes we just got
into it guys I need you to shout that
from the
rooftops yeah you guys are
congratulations H home all right now who
are your biggest cheerleaders on the way
I would say we've got some family that
um was walking the journey along with us
and then my parents um we just like to
talk money you know there's more that's
um caught then taught and it was those
conversations that just kind of kept us
focused and motivated wow that's awesome
so what's next you got a paid for home
no debt life is good what do you do what
do you do to celebrate and don't say ice
fishing
yeah well we came here okay um and then
we've got some fun projects for the
house now that it's all done we've kind
of it's time to have some fun there yeah
and you don't have to take out a HELOC
to do it that's the best part exactly
speed of cash that's so fun all right I
see the kiddos over there um let's bring
them up and then we're going to talk
about them for a second we've got uh
tell us who they are and the ages yeah
we've got Charlotte is 133 Kelvin is 11
and Caleb is seven okay and and so how
quickly did you bring them into this
journey and then how involved were they
in the conversations around this cuz you
just said uh Melissa that you and your
family talk about money I'm guessing
these kiddos have a pretty good idea
about what we're about to do yeah yeah
oh yeah they do they listen to the
podcast with us a lot of the time um we
have the game at home we' played that a
few times um you know our um debt
trackers were up on the fridge so they
saw it the same as we did um so it was
really a family Journey they knew kind
of what the goal was and why we did
things the way we did okay and no
griping no complaining they were pretty
good soldiers nah they're pretty good
they're pretty easy that's awesome well
this is really exciting well listen
before we do the screen I want to let
you know we're also going to give you uh
some gifts here uh one is uh Dave's
Total Money Makeover that's for you to
give to someone else because you guys
have you guys have actually done this
and then baby steps millionaires Dave's
latest book and that's where you guys
are headed uh probably pretty quickly
with the income you guys have so those
are our gift to you all right let's do
this is the team ready the kiddos have
they been practicing they're old enough
to I got to hear you guys all right I
want to hear all those different tones
coming out let's do this thing we've got
Gary Melissa Charlotte Kelvin and Caleb
all from the Minneapolis area they paid
off
$165,000 in 47 months starting out
making $160 and ending at 200,000 Let's
go Team let's hear your dead free scream
3 3 2 1 we're dead
free I heard them all I heard them all
did you I heard every voice little
you're the professional musician did you
pick I picked up all three voices I
don't know what you call that I heard
all of them there was no Harmony but I
heard all three well you're tough you're
a tough one to it's like a judge from
American Idol I would never want to do
that in front of you uh but this is a
great example of how a family's tree as
Dave has said for decades changes so
very very cool true that awesome stuff
all right don't go anywhere we've got to
take a quick break Jade warshaw Ken
Coleman with you this is the Ramy show
we'll be right
[Music]
back
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and mother Hood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
budget
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm Ken
colan Jade warshot joins me the phone
number for you to jump in Isle
8825 5225 8825 5225 we'll take your work
questions your money questions today and
uh don't forget your income is your
greatest wealth building tool and now
more than ever I'm telling you if you're
not making what you want to make the
opportunities are there we want to help
you spend that money wisely as well8
825-5222 Oklahoma City Oklahoma and
that's where Jacob is Jacob how can we
help hey guys thanks for taking my call
sure what's up uh so me and my fiance
are about to be out of pharmacy school
in May and it's about to be a huge 180
from making pretty much you know little
to no money as interns and we're about
to be pharmacists nice uh so I just I
just don't really know where to start I
guess I understand a little bit about
budgeting and you know understanding
where my money is going but I just don't
know 100% where I put my money while
we're saving for things like you know
getting married and uh what's your
what's your income's going to be
individually give us those numbers
roughly individually I expect either one
of us to make 100 to 120 a year I would
say starting out would be pretty pretty
reasonable when do you get
married um so we thought about doing it
this summer but with getting license and
the big test and everything I think
we're going to push it to fall but
really we want to get married you know
as quick as possible but not being
ridiculous you know any debt coming out
of school yes um so I have about 55,000
in student loans and she has about 80 so
135 total and are you guys planning to
live
together we are we are already living
together yeah uhhuh uhhuh what other
debt do you have besides the student
loans um she has about I think 5,000
left on a car okay um a 2013 Jetta and
then I have obviously about $2,500 in a
ring 2500 in a ring okay okay anything
else 2500 yeah uh that is all the debt
that we have so you're living together
you're not combining your money though
right I just want to be
sure so that's the that's the thing I
mean we are going to combine our money
when we're married but obviously day one
when we collect a paycheck we will not
be together right I guess in a bank
account you know right okay here's just
this is me being your big sister for a
moment uh don't postpone the wedding out
of the comfort of your living together
and you're already kind of do you're
doing life marriage in your case is just
the piece of paper and I don't want the
comfort of that to cause you to push
that date even further because that
piece of paper is really important for
you guys protection wise so just a
little note there um so you're going to
be in when you graduate you're going to
be making upwards of $200 to
$240,000 combined uh and you guys
probably won't get married till the fall
so the question is who's paying for the
wedding and how much do you need to save
up that's the first question I mean
that's a great question and I will say
it's pretty early on I proposed like
three days ago on Friday oh
congratulations okay that's cool yeah so
I'm coming down from that high and I'm
trying to think about all this stuff and
this stuff is obviously piling on top of
me where you know those type of
questions um I think I am obviously
going to be paying for the wedding I
don't really know I've heard tradition
that the father is supposed to you know
pay but when I shook his hand and like
you know talked to him and got her
blessing I never even thought about that
stuff I was I was fully thinking that
I'm going to pay for this wedding you
know whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa okay
here's the deal don't assume that let
her bring it up to Pops right you're not
supposed to talk to him about that
anyway you didn't do anything wrong just
a little side note you asked for his
daughter's hand in marriage not what
he's going to pay for I know let her
find out yeah let her dig into that one
for sure but but Jade's right that's a
pretty big checklist item to get mhm
yeah I think that that's really
important to find out and here's the
thing regardless of what they're going
to add you should kind of just decide on
you y'all you two together get together
and say listen what are we willing to
spend uh fiance what can you chip in and
husband to be what will you chip in and
that way you kind of at Le at the very
least you can know your own numbers um
now let's deal with this debt because
you've both got more than half a year to
make some serious Headway on paying off
your debt are you earning anything while
you're finishing up
school I would say the bare minimum just
to get to get there we're going to we're
going to be you know skipping barely
along okay and so really not until
unpent go ahead I'm sorry I was going to
say really not until May you won't have
much even to knock out the ring or the
car 2,000 and
5,000 right just because uh it's an
unpaid internship in the last year of
your pharmacy school and and really the
weekend pay you know we make 50 to you
know $150 a weekend just paying
groceries pretty much right now we're in
a lucky situation that we're staying in
a place that my grandpa owns right now
but we're just staying in a little
apartment so okay okay so when May comes
you're hitting the ground hard you're
saving up for this wedding if there's
anything extra you're paying off your
smallest debt which is the ring and
she's paying off her smallest debt which
is the car it'd be great if you guys
were able to get into I mean with that
salary it's possible that you can both
get into this marriage and both all of
you you both only have your student
loans to go so that's what I'd aim for
and of course like Ken said we're having
that conversation with the dad not you
but she is about whether they're
contributing or not to the wedding and
how familiar are you with our baby steps
Jacob I am not familiar I you know I
hear I need to get on some stuff like
that I've got good brother we're gonna
help you out so here let me just Jade
and I walk you through this really quick
so baby step one is to get
$1,000 in a savings account it's your
rainy day something happens it's only
$1,000 it's low on purpose that means
that as soon as you guys get out of
school or anything beyond your B basic
payments and minimum payments you both
need to establish the $1,000 you got it
and then you take on your IND baby step
two is to take on your individual debts
smallest to largest okay baby step three
is once you've paid off all debt is to
then accumulate three to six months of
your living expenses and baby step four
is now you're going to contribute 15
you're saving 15% of your income to
retirement baby step five is your
funding kids college six pay off the
house seven live and give like no one
else okay none of those are relevant to
you right now we're going to give you
the program we're going to get you all
connected here uh so that you guys can
go through FPU on us that's our wedding
gift are you okay with that Jade I love
it uh but that's where you got to be
right now I mean right out of the gate
Jade he they got to each individually
tackle this until we come together right
let me tell you something um I'm not
opposed and this is what I would do
because you guys are going to start
you're going to start making money in
May wwjd I need you what I would would
do I would secretly go to the courthouse
and get a marriage certificate and be
married on paper oh and I would combine
and start hitting this debt snowball in
May instead of having to wait until you
guys get married in the fall and then in
the fall you just have a celebration and
it's a party I'm like y' been living
together you may as well get married
who's I like this I'm going deeper who's
on the list of the no I think they just
the two of them Jacob what do you think
about this is a rather radical
suggestion radical I Like It by the way
Jacob I mean yeah yeah I I that's I
didn't even think about that I didn't
think about that that's why you call
here it's been three days 100% And by
the way that's wwjd that's what would
Jade do yes okay listen the mean you
have to but I like it the party is for
the people the paper is for the what
does it allow them to do immediately
they can combine their finances and in
in a safe way under the cover of the law
of
matrimony Jacob what do you think your
fiance would say about this
idea that I honestly we feel I mean if
I'm be honest we feel 100% like invested
in each other we feel yeah but that talk
married I'm going be honest we're not
lawfully married but we feel like we're
gonna we know we're gonna spend our
lives together listen everybody thinks
they're going to spend their life
together nobody gets married and goes
I'm GNA spend a couple years with you
and then I'm G peace out no one does
that so I'm not saying that to be
negative but I am saying that to be a
realist in that is a fact there is true
protection under the law for those who
are married so that's why we always just
suggest people do it as quickly as
possible because you never ever know
what's going to take place no one ever
says yes that was the plan all along was
to get married and then we break up or
to get married and then you know I'm not
going to even say anything negative like
that cuz I don't I don't believe that
that's going to happen but you have to
plan and be smart um as though you don't
know what will happen because you don't
so so so we need to do this shouldn't we
also give them every dollar year the
every dollar Queen what can we do we're
giving away Dave stuff I feel I feel
very generous as the wedding gift we
give him Financial Peace University for
sure and that or or like that ramsy plus
bundle that includes the the every
dollar I think you get several months of
every dollar you get Financial Peace
University the Ramsey plus bundle has
all these wonderful coaching and so many
good things in it you get that Jacob
it's our gift to you buddy you guys use
everything we're giving you begin to
have the conversation now about all of
this and understand the baby steps going
to guide you really well great hour Jade
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the ramsy show it's
where we help you win in your money in
your work and in your
relationships alongside the fabulous the
incomparable Jade warshaw I'm Ken
Coleman welcome aboard this shower we're
here to coach you up we're going to have
some fun we will shoot you straight
along the way the number to jump in Isle
8825 5225 8825
5225 Kevin in Reno Nevada starts this
hour off
Kevin hi thanks for taking my call
what's going on what's going on he
didn't quite get that CU from home alone
I got
it oh got it right over the head that's
all right my man how can we help
you uh so I am just recently found you
guys uh so we are just kind of starting
our journey I guess you could call it
and uh the main concern we have is
retirement I um the only retirement we
have as of right now is in aurp a life
insurance to retirement plan and I uh
watched a video last night from you guys
that basically was talking about
infinite banking and it sounded similar
to what we have going and that it was a
dumb idea so I thought I would call and
get some more information about it see
what you thought oh my goodness okay so
I'm just assuming all the other things
are in place um I'm assuming that you
don't have debt I'm assuming that you've
got uh 3 to six months saved before
we've started whatever this path is it's
not a good path but can I just make that
assumption uh yes yeah we don't have any
debt and we do have six months worth of
cash just happened to have it I didn't
know those were baby steps but now I do
so that's pretty sweet um but yeah yep
so how long have you been doing
this about six years we signed up for it
it's about six years ago right when my
first born uh was born okay and so what
did you what did you put in to start and
how has it
grown um we I don't think we put
anything we've just been paying monthly
payments the cash value of it right now
is
18K and we pay uh 400 a month so right
now we're putting in 4,800 a year and
you've been doing that for six
years yes okay um I'm just gonna pull
this up because I love doing this so
let's pretend let's see I'm pulling up
an investment calculator because what I
want you to see is that this is a
terrible investment fair
enough yeah absolutely because I'm just
trying to understand give me one second
Ken help you keep the conversation pre
and a rabbi walk into a bar and no I'm
kidding uh so here's the deal she's
going to pull up the numbers uh you saw
the video did you understand why we
think it's a bad
idea yes um I think so and again is
infinite Banking and these are these the
same thing or they it's very similar in
the idea Concepts yeah philosophy is the
same at the end the day they're you
insurance is insurance and retirement is
retirement you shouldn't be combining
the two because they're not intended to
do the same thing uh insurance is
intended to remove risk that you can't
um handle yourself it's not intended to
make you rich or wealthy it's intended
to replace income for people who were
dependent on your income if something
were to happen to you it's not there to
be what builds you wealth and I'm about
to prove that here so you said that
you've been investing
$400 every month for six years that's so
much okay yeah the first few years were
300 a month and then it stepped up so I
think the first three were 300 a month
okay equaling 3,600 a month or a year
excuse me and then 4,800 for the past
you know sure and your cash value that
you've retained from that is 18,000
which by the way dies if you die you do
not retain cash value in these
situations so you've gotten 18,000 out
of this if you had just taken that money
that $400 a month and invested it in
good growth stock mutual funds Heck if
you had just invested it in the S&P 500
in a just basic index fund that has a
you know normal annualized rate of
return of maybe 8% 10% if you're doing
well in mutual funds you would have had
$40,000 and it would have been all
yours and that's really the end of the
that that for me there's a lot of you
know ins and outs to that conversation
but just simplifying it that's the most
most staggering piece of information
that you're going to receive from this
is the fact that whatever whatever
growth you've accumulated is going to
die with you how old are you I want to
do one more thing I I'm I'm I'm teeing
you up Jade cuz you're ready to punch
the numbers listen I made my argument
how old are you no no this is going to
be more fun you're how old 3 36 okay so
P's 36 do 400 a month between age 36 to
let's call it 66 66 so 30 years I just
want you to see Kevin why we really
prefer this type of investing and I'm
putting this at 8% okay like you can
count on that the S&P 500 you can count
on 10% so that puts you in 30 years if
you just invested $400 a month at 8%
starting with nothing that puts you at
almost
$600,000 okay yeah and that's what the
projections are are you know that's what
we're supposed to be cashing out or have
for retirement at retirement but you're
not on Pace at all
you're you're grossly off
Pace okay which we just proved with the
I mean we just forecasted exactly what
you did the six years and it's you're
not even
close not to mention more how it worked
not to mention that the benefit you
don't keep you don't keep the cash value
if something happened to you today that
cash value is gone so what I would tell
you do is I'd say all right $400 a month
stop it today if you can cash out get
out of it I'd get out of it instantly
and then I would say I'm from now on I'm
taking 15% of my gross monthly income
and I'm investing it in good growth
stock mutual funds and what we teach
here is a mix of four growth growth and
income aggressive growth and
international and you could do that
listen if you just said hey I don't care
about that I would even be happy if you
just invested 15% into index funds any
anything but this is basically what I'm
telling you okay because rate of return
wise you're going to far outpace this
and if you're like let let me just try
to play through a scenario that I think
people care about because I know people
like to borrow against this money and
blah blah blah I would say invest that
money into retirement but if you're like
listen I want access to it and I want to
invest my investments or something like
that you put in a brokerage account to
where you can get to it all I'm saying
is anything that you're doing anything
that I'm saying is better than what
you're doing what you're doing is
probably the worst possible way to
invest your money in an insurance
product and so like I said get term life
insurance well the whole idea was to
just recoup some of that money but yeah
term life insurance I would I would get
out of this policy I'd get term life in
in place first and then I'd get out of
this policy you know pick up a 20-year
term it's so cheap and you're going to
be covered and remember the whole point
of this ultimately is that we're
self-insuring and so if you're walking
your the baby steps as we teach by the
time you're 50 or 60 you will have
accumulated so much wealth because
you're going to be investing from this
point on 15% into retirement you're not
even going to need life insurance
because at that point you can assume the
risk because remember the whole point of
that was to cover the risk now you'll be
wealthy enough to assume that risk on
yourself and so this is how this works
this is what wealthy people do thanks
for the call Kevin trust us you don't
want to invest in Insurance just think
about that sentence does that make any
sense if it does this is not the show
for you this is the r
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me we're here
for you America triple
88255 225 if you're new to the program
we take your money questions we take
your work related questions we take your
relationship questions cuz they kind of
all blend together in fact it's rare
that we take a call like that where
there's not some work component some
relationship component so we're here for
you America 8825
5225 the ramsy show question of the day
is brought to you by our good friends at
neighborly your hub for Home Services
there are a lot of things you need to
remember when the weather gets cold
thankfully neighborly has a free winter
maintenance checklist that can help save
you time and hassle and a side note if
you're a like me their maintenance
checklist Jade does save me thousands of
dollars because they just do basic
reminders to things that I don't even
know about so it's huge check it out at
neighbor.com Ramsey that's neighbor.com
Ramsey today's question comes from
Dalton in California he says my current
salary is based on pandemic consulting
salaries so if my contract is not
renewed I would likely be earning $10 to
$30 less per hour than I make now is
stability and benefits of a job of a
full-time job worth the potential
$50,000 pay cut probably not I'm going
to say 99.9% of the time not and the
reason I say that Dalton is
because um stability is the wrong word
to lean on here in the first place this
is the very job where you may be taking
A10 to $30 an hour pay cut I don't
consider that stable we're talking about
a wob table at best at least one of
those legs is wobbling if you're
potentially going to lose that kind of
income secondly and I've said this a
million times benefits play to our
safety gland obviously it it everybody
needs and health insurance is is
obviously a a tremendous value however
when you start comparing insurance plans
I would always take the better job
meaning better pay better environment I
enjoy the work and I've got a ladder for
growth which means financial growth I'm
going to take that better opportunity
over the better health care plan and
whatever else the benefits are I mean if
it's sense it's just usually it's just
not a huge difference so I never uh give
anybody advice to take a job on benefit
packages alone uh because trust me
that's going to wear off pretty quickly
and in this case let's say you stay at
this current job that you think is
stable and I think is wobbly you take a
pay cut but you love those benefits
versus let's go out and let's have a
backup plan you know when we get on a
plane the the lovely flight attendant
and and folks get up there and they tell
us about where we go in case of
emergency landing and I want to have
that same exit pattern laid out for
myself professionally and I'm telling
you I've always practiced that I still
practice that uh and so at this case if
I knew this and I'm you Dalton Jade I
I'm immediately going okay uh where does
my skill set and experience allow me to
potentially land let me start looking
for options so that I got options and
and the healthcare and the benefits
usually take care of himself so no I
would not stay take a huge hit which
could be 50 Grand that's a big hit I
would do that's a big hit I would not do
that what's that called what's that
called because like in in money let's
say you have a piece you invested in a
job opportunity or a business or
property and it's failing but you keep
pouring money into it we call it sunk
cost fallacy cuz it's like I've come
this far I may as well keep rri out even
though every all signs point to the fact
that this sucks what is it called in a
career when you feel the need to cling
onto to something that is sinking like
it's it's losing you money it's it's
it's it's not good what do they call
that is that a word um it's not a word
but I'm going to call it this phrase it
means that we'd rather be miserable than
uncomfortable oo what that means is is I
know what I'm dealing with I'm going to
take a big pay cut and it's going to
suck or I'm dealing with a toxic leader
or I've got gossipy co-workers and I
hate going in but I'm going to keep
doing it because the the the fact that
I'm
miserable doesn't matter because at
least I know what I'm up against and I
know what I got to deal with and I got
to bite a stick hold my nose you pick
the analogy versus going I got to face
my fears right and step into the unknown
of what else could be out there and I
leave one place that I'm miserable in
yeah to go to a place where I might be
uncomfortable for a little while but
ultimately better off so I think the
dynamic there is what you're what you've
so expertly pointed out is our comfort
factor yeah uh you've seen the
motivational posters who knows who said
it but you know life is on the other
side of comfort and and all that and and
that's what's going on with people will
stay in a job like this with those cost
cuz they go at least I know it and you
can see the fear in this question this
person is rationalizing this is an
otherwise very sharp individual this
dude yeah and he's
rationalizing swallowing a $50,000 pay
cut rationalizing well the benefits are
good uh Dalton I'll bet you the benefits
are good at other companies as well and
you don't take a $50,000 hit so I think
at the core of it what do you think I
think it's fear of the unknown yeah I
think it's that old adage that's like
the the the enemy of best is just fine
right it's like oh this is fine like my
life's fine it's good it's it's good the
enemy great yeah and it's like it keeps
you from getting to that best yeah it's
like at Home Depot where they have the
good the better and the best quality
yeah the paintbrush and you're like you
go with the one that is you know it's
not good quality but you're like well
it's not going to cost me much in the
moment so you go with that then you get
home you start painting and you're like
I should have just spent and got the one
that was best interesting that you make
this point because when it comes to the
Ramsey Show in the uh wine taste test
you brought in a party platter we
recently tested and um I chose the uh I
chose the good wine the good not the
better wine good wine tastes I know but
I'm pointing out that you make a very
good point here don't scrimp on the
paint scrimp on the wine that's is that
what I'm hearing I'm only learning from
you yes but does it have like a a ring
to it like I'm trying to I'm trying to
get to where you're at Ken no it doesn't
have a ring I don't know what I'm doing
I just thought it's interesting that you
said uh maybe you don't do that but then
you're telling me teaching me to do the
uh knockoff cookies and chips and the in
the and the wine listen quality I'm
learning all the way around quality over
Comfort is that good can we say that we
can just say the the Comfort place is a
great place to be but nothing grows
there yeah leave it at that never mind
used to say the last 30 seconds of what
I said just go ahead and scrub it from
your memory apparently I'm just it just
I'm learning I'm learning this budgeting
thing all right Men In Black style well
here's the deal it's over I tend to to
lean always towards the
better always it's going to here's
here's where the analog here's where the
analogy is better car so it lasts longer
all these things yeah it's going to have
you're going to have to come out of
pocket you got to save get to get what's
better got to save that's it there you
go I like it all right let's see here uh
let's go this is a quick one investing
question from Brandy in New Orleans poor
Brandy she had to sit there and listen
to that last minute Brandy what's your
question hi Ken hi Jade my question is
my husband and I both 22e Public School
teachers and we're about four five and
six okay and we're trying to figure out
are we going
to we have 8% taken out for our state
pension plan they take 8% so are we
taking 15% on top of the 8% are we doing
7% to meet the 8% and are we putting it
in a 403b or are we putting in out R Ira
okay so let me make sure I understand
the school takes 8% of your paycheck
each of your paychecks and puts it into
the 403b right uh no they put it into a
state pension plan for our retirement
403b is extra for us okay so and on your
403b like do you get to choose the
Investments like a 401k it's got some
good investment options that you get to
select we can choose the investment mix
okay as far as particular and the stock
investment or whatever no but we can
choose the mix okay so large cap value
small mid okay good good okay so what I
would say is for those listening
obviously we want to get to 15% of your
gross income so because the money
they're taking 8% of your money you
don't get to choose with that pension
and it doesn't have a great rate of
return so let's pretend that each of
that for you guys counts instead of it
counting at 8% count at about half and
then do the rest whatever is made up
into your 403b make sure you're choosing
a good mix growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international and
you should be set so again instead of
counting it at 8% count it at 4% and do
the other 11 into that
403b all right great stuff thank you for
the call and thank you both for teaching
and serving in that way this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me the phone
number for you to jump in is 8825 5225
that's
88255 225 let's go to Cincinnati Ohio
where Heaven
awaits Heaven how can we help yes so hi
how you doing how that I'm talking to
Heaven I don't know that it gets much
better than this professionally that's
what's your middle name all right well
it's actually me it's honey in Spanish
if you know Spanish okay well you I
don't but this is great you learn
something new every day Heaven this is
awesome how can we help
you well I am 29 single with no kids and
I I just heard about this show and I'm
hoping that you could give me some
really good advice I um I'm in about 60
$5,000 in debt I live with my mom and I
have a low a low paying job I grew up
with four um poor financial habits and
even in moments of having money I didn't
build wealth like I really wanted to I
just got deeper into financial debt now
I'm feel now I'm feeling scared and
stuck I really don't know I I don't want
to keep depending on people to loan me
money for me to pay back and yeah just
stay broke and I'm just sick of
constantly being in in the cycle so if
you can offer any help or anything and I
heard about the class but I don't have
$80 either let me tell you something let
me get that out of the way all right
we're going to take care of that I want
to ask you really quickly about your job
and possibilities before Jay takes over
on the debt because she can give you the
plan okay I'm just curious what are you
doing for a
living I work at a middle school I'm an
IIA sure absolutely love love love love
our IIA we've had some amazing IAS in
our life uh for our kiddos and so thank
you for that work so but you've got the
degree correct or am I right about that
so I have my associates in Psychology
and I haven't finished my bachelor okay
great because of I can't pay what do you
get what do you get paid I get paid $779
a check
$779 you get two of those I get two of
those a month and that's after taxes and
and I have health insurance and whatnot
so okay def all right and I don't want
to get bogged down here but this is a
part of the equation um what what are
your opportunities if you just think
about what you have done do you think
about what is a better paying job a path
for you to where you are making 4050
$60,000 $70,000 a year have you thought
through that absolutely so okay so what
I did was sign up for to to be a a inare
provider and home care provider which
starts at about $25 an hour but it also
gives me flexibility and time you know
to do other things also because I wanted
to do that plus work as an IIA because I
I love my job it just don't pay nothing
got it okay good yeah so here's here's
the deal and I have a juicing business
I'm starting go ahead what
business so I'm starting a juicing
business um I eventually I wanted to
grow but right now I'm just starting off
um just selling juices from stores and
um stands and whatnot so that's also
like going to be kind of Inc so real
quick I want to hand you over to Jade
and Jay's going to walk you through how
to get out of this debt but I'm glad
you've thought of some things let me
tell you this about the juicing thing I
don't want to discourage you in any way
but that needs to be your third job
right now if you have time for it and
and or a second job if we go and we get
a better job but I like the idea of what
you have mapped out and I'm going to
tell you you need to pursue that with
the same abandon that you need to pursue
these baby steps that Jay's going to
walk you through because your ability to
make more money right now while living
with mom is huge so you've got to treat
that as lifegiving like I have got to
make more money and if you can go get
something that will allow you to keep
the IIA job and that's extra money great
you hear me but you have got to be crazy
intense about making more money right
now then Jay's going to tell you what to
do with it all right sweet thank you so
much all right all right uh yes Ken good
job um okay my two cents here is I can
can walk you through the baby steps
you're not going to be able to do too
too much until you get your income up
which is what Ken suggested and I might
also offer this little piece which is I
want you to get your income up so that
you can pay your debt off I think that's
really important but I think the most
important move that you're going to make
in all of this is moving out of your
mom's house because what you describe to
me was a cycle and it sounds like a
cycle that you're trying to break and
it's very very hard to break break a
cycle when you're right literally living
in the midst of it so it's Qui you know
what I'm saying cuz you got to deal with
everybody else's mindsets too cuz your
mom has an opinion you know Auntie comes
over she has an opinion everybody's got
an opinion so I really want to get you
in a place financially where you're able
to remove yourself from that position
that's going to be so so so so so
important because here's the thing
here's what I know you start making some
money you start making some Headway and
people see it now now you're the one
who's got
money and now everybody's coming to you
and that just adds another layer of all
right I got to tell these folks no I got
to tell them you know I'm trying to do
my thing so just let that marinate
somewhere in the back um your position
as a IIA is it 40 hours a week or do you
have a good amount of extra time it's um
it's 40 hours a week but I got it's it's
from 7:30 to 2:30 okay and you don't
have kids so until until you move into
this home healthcare thing where you're
doing 4,000 and more
I really really want you to pick up
something that's earning you any money
and I say this to anybody listening
sometimes we wait around because we're
like it's not making maybe the money
that I think I should be making but in
this case making any money is better
than not making any right so you going
over and picking up um whatever it is
instacart I know folks who make you know
can make $1,000 in a weekend on
instacart and that's not even including
your your afternoons after school so I
think that you can be double your income
just by you picking up
anything okay right so that's that's
what we're doing as we work towards this
Home Health Care idea um your 65,000 of
debt can you tell me what kind of debt
it is right quick um my car my car I owe
about 20,000 on that okay and then
College stuff um pass Banks but that's
it's the college in the car that's most
of it but like student
yeah how much student Lo and I haven't
even started paying on those but that's
about 20,000 okay so 20,000 car 20,000
student loans I'm missing 25 because you
said 65 oh yeah so that's just um like
um like there's a car a old car that I
have to pay out that I really haven't
started um and that's about that's about
700 I owe a bank about um
1,000 um One Bank about a thousand and a
couple more Banks about around that much
like around
500 um what else so a couple a couple of
$500 ones a couple of thousand do ones
those are just little personal loans
like micro loans yeah okay and then
we've got the credit card for 700 I feel
like I'm still we're still missing a
good chunk yeah we we're still missing
stuff I gave that number just based off
of I don't know I'm okay just
ballparking L but the car the car and
college are the most you know right
what's your car payment strength of
things my car payment is 647 girl o
heaven what's the car worth oh man well
she's selling it we gonna sell it he are
you upside down you got equity in
it um I think it's upside down I mean
works fine but I definitely got um I
it's I got this crappy payments because
my credit up how far away from work do
you how far away from work are
you not far about 10 10 minutes 10
minutes
listen I want you out of this car and if
you're upside down if you call them and
you find out you're up upside down I
want you to do anything you can do to
get out of this C payment so let's say
it's worth 20 let's say you owe 20 but
it's worth $18 you got to come up with
$2,000 any way you can in any way that
you can that is legal cuz I want you out
of this car payment because
$647 would be everything to you right
now yeah and and and you live close
enough to work you get you a $2,000 car
or you walk or you jog or you get one of
those Razor scooters but we're getting
extreme because listen K scooter when
you have to break these Cycles you have
to go into the extreme because all of
that
gravitational is trying listen that
gravitational pool will break her ankles
so she might as well get on a Razor
scooter but she's got to get free I I
condone all of it except for the razor
scooter get you a Razor scooter and get
you the kids will think you're cool oh
boy I don't know this is the Ramy
[Music]
shop
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation about your life with you
here on the ramsy show it's America show
because we're talking about things that
no other show talks about
your money your work and your
relationships all together we want you
to win Triple 8 825 5 225 is the number
The Fabulous Jade warshaw joins me I'm
Ken Coleman I'm not fabulous you're all
right Ken here all right I'm all right
I'll take that I'm all right that's
about as good as it gets I'll take it I
got three teens I'm never right I'm
being told all the time I'm cringe oh my
daughter likes to tell me dad you're so
cringe oh man I don't know any of that
means although every once in a while you
teach me a word here on the show that I
take home and they kind of look at me
like where did he come up with that and
I don't reveal my source tell tell your
boys next time that you guys are having
a you know it's you against them yeah be
like I I'm telling you such says and I'm
standing on business tell them you stand
on business stand on business stand on
bus stand on business all right I will
guarantee I can't wait to see what they
say yeah yeah James I'll mess that up
for sure it'll come out completely
different than that but I'll try
speaking of standing on business Kathy
is joining us I'm confusing millions of
people uh as we speak and I the great
part is I have no idea what it means
Kathy's joining us in Milwaukee Kathy
how can I
help hi Ken hi Jade hey how are you
what's up I have a question on baby step
three getting my larger emergency fund
Okay so we've me and my husband are both
on board we paid off all of our debt and
we started sinking funds do I include
the syncing funds like the balance of
those in my 3 to six months no because
the syncing funds are going towards
future needs that you know you're going
to it's just future purchases whereas
the emergency fund is strictly for
emergencies and emergencies are things
that are um completely necessary
completely unavoidable and have a uh
urgent time frame is what I would kind
of call those three things that you're
looking for it's some something that you
know it's uh oh my goodness you lose a
job and so you have a little bit you
know you don't have enough money to
fully make ends meet so that would be
you pulling a little bit maybe from your
emergency fund or something that you're
unable to cash flow but it's necessary
for it to happen right away HVAC HVAC
right and so syncing funds really
doesn't fall into that syncing funds is
just a way for us to save separate money
so in essence in essence you kind of
have two savings accounts you've got
your emergency refund and then you've
got separate money that you're saving up
for things that you just want to do in
life okay so even if it's not like I get
annual purchases that I know are going
to happen that I save up for but for
example like if I'm saving for a new car
right but see and that's why you use
this framework unexpected saving for a
new car is not unexpected so that would
not be emergency fund that would be
separate
savings okay does that kind of help you
so unexpected um completely necessary
and Urgent time frame are the three Cate
boxes that must be ticked am I leaving
anything out Ken I don't think though
it's pretty good you got it Kathy I
think so fantastic thanks for calling
the show appreciate it really fun let's
go to Megan now in Salt Lake City Utah
Megan how can we
help Ken Jade I can't believe I'm
talking to you this is awesome we feel
the same way about you we really do we
can't believe we're talking to Megan
yeah what's up
um so I have a question regarding how to
manage and stay within the 25% of my
take-home pay um when my rent keeps
going up every year it was 25% when I
moved in and now it has been increased
to
28% and I'm trying to save for a house
I'm currently in um baby step four but I
don't know if it would be considered 3B
because I have a fully funded emergency
fund but I'm not doing 15% in retirement
because I'm trying to save for a house
yeah how much do you have saved
up huh how much do you have saved up for
your house payment down payment oh I
just I just got started I'm about 3,000
okay so there's a couple of things I
want to address with this so you're
you're you're telling me you've gone up
from 25% and for anybody listening our
rule of thumb here is we really don't
want your mortgage or your rent to be
any more than 25% of your take-home pay
when it starts creeping up and up
especially if you don't see a plan to be
able to match it with the income and
kind of smash it back down um so that's
what she's talking about so you're
upwards to 28% now it's kind of got you
worried especially with you trying to do
this down payment do you see a a course
to where you're able to up your income
3% yes I'm currently working a second
job and uh I get a raise every year
that's around 5 to 7% great and I won't
get that raise until August but I'm just
kind of worried because I want to stay
within the guidelines and I think Davis
said you could go as high as 30% but 25
is is best and I'm just 25 is best
margin yeah let's look at real numbers
how much has your rent actually gone up
don't give me percentage how
when I moved in it was
950 and then he raised it my landlord
raised it to 1,00 this year and I think
I factored it was about 27 or
28% so you go up you go up $150 I mean I
get it like that that sucks you're like
man what um but I love that you've got
something that can cover it here's the
thing you're doing extra work you're
you're trying to accomplish a goal you
want every cent of that money to go
towards a goal but one of the realities
of renting is you do have to deal with
rent increases and in this case you know
unless you say to me Jade and I know of
a place down the street where I can rent
for 850 my lease is up in May and I can
go do it then I'm like yes go do it um
so you're going to have to kind of
decide a couple of factors you're going
to think to yourself okay how long
realistically is it going to take me to
save for this down payment okay and I
don't know how long you've been living
in this apartment but you can also look
at historically how how often and how
much have they raised the rent if you've
been living there for 10 years and they
never raised the rent and this was the
first time then I'd probably be willing
to wait it out a little bit but if
you're seeing every single year it's
going up $1 $150 and you're like listen
Jade I don't know if I want to wait it
out my term is about to be or my leas is
about to be up then you've got options
there you're not locked in but I don't
to Ken's point I don't want you to over
freak out over the 150 um unless it
really starts to become a problem
because here's where I'm looking I'm
kind of looking
longterm around the Horizon but on baby
step 4 if that if this is going to take
you more than 2 years to save for your
down payment after two years I'm going
to tell you Hey listen you need to start
putting something aside even if it's 5%
or up to your match because I don't want
you pushing off retirement any longer
than maybe a 2 threee window to say for
this down payment is that
fair yes and I'm and I am doing uh 5%
match on my 401K with my employer okay
and um and because I put retirement off
for way too long when I was in baby step
2 so I don't really want to stop
retirement and you don't have to just
Megan I was just wanting to yes Ken
question are you
single I am single okay um I I gotta
tell
you I'm I'm I'm I'm kind of using the
spirit animal of George Campbell because
if he were sitting here with me he would
be recommending that that you have a
roommate for a season um you want to get
your own home anyway and if you could
get a roommate now all of a sudden this
is a game Cher for you um and especially
if we can go 5050 I love it consider it
I really would let's do a champ
roommate would require a move I have a
studio apart oh you have a studio would
require move what I'm trying to avoid
well you're okay I don't want to want to
move I understand but you said it and I
want to remind you Dave has mentioned
many times that these things are
guidelines this is not you being
irresponsible this is not you going out
and getting too much rental property it
is what it is if you can find a cheaper
place like Jade said great um but right
now I think more income is your play
this has not gone up really crazy you're
going to get a a maybe a 5 to 7% bump on
your salary watch your budget the extra
income between your discipline and the
extra income you're going to be okay but
do be watch freak out about it Be
watchful in your complex because of if a
a one-bedroom or some a situation comes
available where you can look at the
numbers and go listen with a roommate I
could pack in a little bit more do Be
watchful for that yeah and I know you
don't want to move but if the move
improves your your your financial
situation so much more uh I'd say the
ROI is worth it but you're okay you're
not breaking the rules this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
n
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically in your money in your work
and in your relationships
8825 5225 is the phone number 88255 225
your One Call Away from some hope uh
we're going to be honest with you we're
going to have some fun as well speaking
of fun uh the incomparable the
combustible Jade
warshaw uh combustible you can be
combustible in a good way you're kind of
like um Catching Fire you're like the
the the the star of the movie uh uh uh
Hunger Games thank you catniss thank you
you've got you've got that you remember
who her costume designer was listen
that's better that's better than Mr who
is her costume designer I don't know Ken
the one the only speaking of
incomparable Lenny Kravitz I did not
know that Lenny Kravitz played her
costume designer and to designed the
combustible costume good to know but
this just speaking to your charisma and
enthusiasm which I enjoy it is
infectious we're here together I'm Ken
Coleman I don't know that I mentioned
that she's Jade warshaw and and speaking
of combustible yes um you you and your
amazing social media
specialist uh have come up with some fun
Clips recently of the two of us and I
feel like I'm just I feel like I'm next
to one of the big shots like I'm just
one of the Supremes next to the star you
know I don't know but it's been fun it
has been fun and there have been several
so one of them you tell me has uh
garnered quite the uh reaction and dare
I say is there an overwhelming amount of
criticism for you uh I don't know that I
would call it overwhelming you saying
what were you saying to me okay so in
the clip here's what I in the here's
what I want you guys to know we post
these clips from the show on our social
media and we like we're on social media
like we're watching it we're reading the
comments so you know we posted today a
clip and let's just play it so you guys
can see it oh okay here we
go if you have time to watch Netflix you
have time to get a side hustle let me
just say it like that why' you have to
go and do that I'm just saying making us
all feel guilty for sitting there and
watching some I'm just saying do
something during that time I have a
buddy that I follow online and she does
the surveys you know you can do the
surveys and it's like there there is
always something you can do to make
money even if it's a little bit there's
always something you can do with that
extra 30 minutes here and 40 minutes
there okay so there you have it so I'm
clearly being factious I agree with you
get after you shouldn't be watching
Netflix if you're broke yeah but folks
are saying different they're giving us
some grief yeah somebody said while it
makes sense let's not underestimate the
value of rest some hobbies and doing
something that also makes you happy
listen yeah but not not now like you got
to get out of debt first like you got to
earn your rest like rest when you sleep
yeah like it it says let no what do ises
that what does the scripture say no
sleep to your to your eyes no Slumber
deliver yourself like a gazelle from the
hand of the hunter like and I know
that's not exactly literal but there is
a piece to when you're getting out of
debt you have to be willing to sacrifice
and do things that right people who
aren't in debt don't have to do which me
I can watch Netflix tonight you know why
cuz I'm not broke I do think that
there's something to be said for working
to the point of a couple good shows I'm
into right now sorry I interrupted you
sorry sorry I'm over in my own in a r I
was just thinking about what do I got in
the queue
tonight but but you make a very good
point though what you were saying in
this clip is you don't need to be
watching Netflix you need to be working
until it's time to fall into the bed
because you're exhausted and we all say
that you know we all say we don't have
time oh I I would do it if I had time
and I'm like listen you go and do a Time
audit and see where your time is being
spent and I bet you and when I say A
Time audit everybody should do this
practice a couple times a year really
Journal out what you're doing from sunup
to sundown all the time what time you
woke up what you did after that what you
did after that and really start seeing
where your time is going and I think
that you'll be shocked at how much time
you can find throughout the day and cuz
here's the thing it might not be in Big
Blocks and you might learn like listen I
need to scoot my around so that I can
create blocks of time or you might
realize listen I could wake up an hour
and a half earlier or I could go you
know I could stay up or like there stay
up later there's things that you can do
and uh I don't want to create
excuses and reasons why I can't get
where I need to go cuz ultimately and I
get don't get me wrong rest is important
I get it but here we're trying to
motivate your butt to get out of debt so
when I'm telling you to to go pick up
jobs don't come at me with like but Jade
we need to rest you'll have time to rest
what else are they saying is there
anything else in there let's see a
little bit more I'd like to know some
more this person said why did you have
to go and say that Jade um this person
said rest and live within your means and
I'm like I'm talking to folks who are
trying to get out of debt now what I
like is what Julie 9658 said she said
all right Jade I needed this I hear you
deleting Netflix that's the kind of
energy I'm rocking with W Julie 956
very literally I need the person who
looks at it and says oh this person is
giving me away they're showing me how to
get to succeed yeah I bet she's her
username on Netflix Julie 2568 whatever
it is I just think that's really funny
that that's what she went with it just
cracks me of I think that you make a
very good point and I agree with you by
the way I got to say I don't know if
sometimes people realize that I'm being
like factious in that clip when I said
come on Jade why do you got to do but
come on I think you're right I think
watching TV let me tell you this
millionaires don't watch a lot of TV
multi-millionaires billionaires they
don't watch a lot of TV listen they
really don't we can tell people I'mma
get into it we can tell who said what to
who you can tell me what Taylor Swift
said to what's his guy's name I don't
even know the guy's name oh her
boyfriend the football this is what's
wrong with America everybody knows her
but we don't know who he is but I'm
saying my daughter walks into the living
room last night and she sees the Chiefs
are on true story she's like oh is
Taylor there
that's what she said and I'm just like
go out of the room leave the room now go
to your room I can't handle it his name
is Travis Kelce by the way Travis Kelsey
folks can quote exactly what Jay-Z spent
on a meal people can quote really yes
people know numbers but they don't know
their own numbers they can tell you
exactly what somebody else's plan is and
what they're doing with their money and
their business but they don't even know
what's going on in the state of their
own life and they're they would rather
spend time gathering information and
gossip about celebrities going out and
getting your own life together like
that's not your life that's fake or we
spend time on social media scrolling and
looking at other people's lives
comparing ourselves to other people's
Liv we'll spend more time hold on I'm
about to get him Ken boy we'll spend
more time looking for the right lighting
to take a photo than we'll spend looking
for the right side hustle it's a very
good point you are 100% correct I should
built stuff and and then here's the deal
they they then they're griping and
they're exhausted and all this rest when
you're what you're really exhausted from
is the stress you're exhausted from the
stress you can't sleep enough and you'll
rest better when the Deb's gone yeah but
you want to watch your shows you want to
you want by the way it's not just
Netflix anymore what is the deal there's
75 platforms that you got to pay for to
watch everything
hulu plus plus plus back in the day you
used to say I got to watch my stories
remember that I don't ever remember
saying that oh soap operas be like oh my
stories are on today she knows what I'm
talking about I got to watch watch my St
yes I will say this for about a
six-month period that I regret James I
did watch Days of Our Lives during uh
College yeah I know about that yeah then
I'm never getting that time back no
you're not all right the good news is
we'll be back before you know it's a
very quick commercial break don't move
this is the Ramy
show
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshot joins you we're
here for youle 8825
5225 is the phone number for you to jump
inle
8825 5225 let's go to Jesse now in
Buffalo New York Jesse how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking my call I'm
just trying to some advice on how to
navigate um kind of the disposable
income I have at this point so tell us
what you got that's
disposable well so I pull in about 3,300
a month that's my take-home um and my
current expenses including the
contributions I already have um to my
like retirement accounts and that's kind
of the the the core of the question here
um so I'm pulling 3,300 I have about
2500 in expenses right now so I have
about a th000 bucks a month that I'm I'm
not really really doing much with at the
moment and you have no debt I have no
debt I'm very lucky that I have no debt
do you have an emergency fund I do I
have about $3,000 in the savings account
okay and are you investing at all 401K
at work any kind of Investments so
that's that's really the core of the
question I am pretty uh focused on
investment at this point in my life so I
have a uh rtht and a traditional IRA
through Vanguard and that has about
$30,000 in it currently I have a 401k
through my employer I just started so
that only has about $600 but I'm
contributing $200 a pay period to that
and then I have a why I I used to work
for the YMCA which I'm not sure if
you're aware they're a great company to
retire with because they match 12% um
and just for years of doing that I have
about $20,000 sitting there great so how
old are you I'm 32 okay you're 32 um
good I'm listening to everything I hear
it sounds good what's your living
situation so I live with my partner we
have a monthly uh rent of 1,600 and then
utilities cap out about I would say $200
a month so between the two of us we're
looking at a little under 2,000 per
month okay and you just split the rent
everything is just split right down the
middle yep SPL right down the middle so
what the of all the things you said the
thing that sticks out to me most first
is that that you only have 3,000
saved so the way we would teach is for
you to have at least three to six months
saved so I would beef that up and I'm I
shouldn't have jumped forward but do you
have any other debt no no I'm very lucky
um I my I was I got help with my
undergrad and then I didn't do grad
school until I had the money for it okay
excellent so no debt The Next Step then
is to save up what would be Ain to 3 to
six months of expenses and I'm not going
to lie the way I just I love when people
have six months so if you can get six
months considering um you're not
technically married and you know so
you're treating you're treating your
income as a single guy and so I do 6
months of savings um since you're the
only one who funds your lifestyle um so
that would be next and then I would walk
with that extra ,000 that you have after
you've beefed up your savings I'd walk
down the additional baby steps with you
so uh if you don't see saving for kids
college anywhere in your near future I'd
want to make sure that uh you're
definitely saving 15% so what percentage
are you at at this point so I'm putting
a about $500 a month into my Roth and
then
$200 uh per pay period so $400 a month
into my the uh the I have a 401k through
Equitable okay so is that a part just to
clarify you still have $800 in
additional money Surplus even after
doing those two things yes sir okay okay
so what percentage because only you know
your gross pay I want you investing 15%
of your gross pay every month okay so
that's before insurance comes out that's
before taxes so you know look on your
pay stub or whatever or however you get
paid and figure out what 15% is cuz
that's what I want you doing and you're
going to mix it across like what you
said if you've got if you've got a match
on your 401k invest up to that match and
then go over to your Roth and try to Max
that out and if you still have money to
go come back to the 401K and try to Max
that out and for you go ahead oh I'm so
sorry uh so that that's really the
question I have so I'm on a bit of a
grind and like I'm at an age right now
where I've shifted Focus to how do I
really maximize uh these retirement
contributions uh so I I work full-time I
have like a main job I'm a school social
worker okay but I also have two
part-time jobs okay um and I'm actually
going to be getting another job that's
going to be seasonal okay um so all all
of this to say is like really I there's
a lot of my money that I can be Ma I I
maxed out my IRA last my Roth out last
year okay I'm I'm on track to Max it out
this year um I don't think I'd be able
to max out Equitable just because that's
that's about 23,000 I could put into
there and I don't think I'd get there
but the thoughts I'm having right now is
I have all these different spots and
obviously it's not going to hurt me but
is there something better I could be
doing with that money because I have so
I stopped work so that that's a question
um I'm not sure what that looks like
right now you know it's you don't have
but do you feel like at some point
you're going to buy a house I mean
you're 32 I would assume at some point
you want to buy a home yeah yeah that's
true I would be I mean right you don't
have to know what the price of the house
is down the line but you can start
saving at this point you're doing a
really good job with investing if you do
what Jade says in our baby steps we have
what's called 3B which is saving for a
home and so right now at your age I
would start socking away some money for
a house down payment in the future that
may be three years from now I don't know
but if you think if you think it's more
of a fiveyear like a 5year or longer
play I'd probably take whatever money
that you think listen this might be my
my down payment or my home money and i'
just put it in a brokerage account
invested in an index fund and let it sit
as long as you know it's at least a
5year play because we just see that the
chances of you having a positive return
on your investment is better at the
5-year Point than it would be at say the
two or threee point and so that's what I
would do I would start focusing on the
idea of buying a house with a super high
down payment or you know dream a little
and be like listen what would it look
like if I one day paid cash and bought a
piece of real estate completely in cash
because it seems like you're really in a
Money Motivated mode right now and I'm
not mad at that like you're like I'm
really to do what it takes and
technically the state you're at you
could just continue to pile up
Investments listen maxing out a 401k
maxing out a Roth IRA maxing out
whatever other uh situation you said you
had there that's all good like all that
stuff is compounding over time um and if
that's your goal there's nothing wrong
with that but I do think that to Ken's
Point real estate is going to sneak
around the corner before you know it and
if you've been paying attention to
anything going on is it's harder and
takes people longer to save up to buy a
house than ever before so it might
behoove you to kind of get that process
started uh that way when you're ready to
buy the money is just sitting there and
you have your pick of the litter okay
yeah yeah I think I I've just been so
focused on retirement because of that
compounding aspect but then I'm
wondering if yeah what are the other
things I could be doing with that money
that would be beneficial and that makes
a lot of sense yeah I look at be things
sometimes wake up and I feel like I'm on
track sometimes I wake up I feel like
I'm behind sometimes I wake up I feel
like I'm ahead really hard to you're not
let's think about it let's let's do some
math because I love bringing up a
retirement C calculator you said you are
and I'm just on the Ramsey Solutions
retirement calculator you said you're 32
years old Let's Pretend Social Security
starts at 62 so let's just say at 62 you
decide that you're going to be done with
things and let's pick the 401K since you
already have $600 in there and let's say
that each month your contrib ruting how
much to your
401k 400 let's say four another $400 all
right let's pretend it's getting a 9%
rate of return even though we could
probably do more just in a S&P 500
that's just in that account alone if you
only for the rest of the next 30 years
of your life only put $400 in that
account that account would have $741,000
in it just that account and don't forget
you're also maxing out Roth IRAs and
you've got these other accounts through
your work so that should give you some
hope that yeah you're going to be just
fine and you've got a long you know you
got a long path to do a lot of great
things here yeah yeah yeah definitely I
think the one of the catalysts for for
this changeing mindset was uh setting up
the Equitable account and seeing my
retirement M retirement uh Year date
being 2060 and just being like well
that's really not that far away yeah
getting kind of freaked out by that
listen a lot happens in 30 years a lot
happens in 30 years and I like that
you're Diversified in a lot of different
accounts like sometimes people think
it's just one big nest egg and one
account can and that's not the case I
mean you've got a lot going on here and
you'll soon add real estate to your
portfolio too and we've seen that most
millionaires do have a paid for home as
well so adding that to the mix is going
to be very very good for you as well
yeah Jesse you're on a great path you
don't have to freak out just continue to
be disciplined uh if you haven't found
someone to really help guide you go to
ramsy solutions.com and click on
smartvestor Pro find some of those folks
in your area go interview them see who's
the best fit for you having someone to
guide you uh and explain it and teach it
to you to where you understand it it's
going to give you even more confidence
thanks for the call this is the rangy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me 8825
5225 is the phone number and uh this is
a show built on basic baby steps that
get people out of debt and allow them to
live a life that they have dreamed of
and there's no better example of that
than when we have our debt free screams
and as I look across the studio I see
two fabulous people by the names of Joe
and Cat and they're on the debt free
stage Joe cat welcome thank you glad to
be here where are you guys from We're
from Floyd Knobs Indiana okay good all
right and you're here to do a debt free
scream I presume right fantastic all
right give us the numbers here let's
walk through this how much debt did you
pay off and how long it was 12 22,7 49
took about 60 months 60 months and what
did that in uh well let me first ask you
what was your range of income during
that time uh
125,000 okay stayed at 125 that's very
good what do you do for a living I'm a
registered nurse okay great fantastic
and what was the debt comprised of the
749 well it ranged from uh credit card
debt to um our house payment hey there
you go paid for house well no I take
that back we didn't pay for our house
yet we're still trying to okay okay so
what was the 122 749 some of that's what
you've paid in the house or what help me
out uh we did pay um some the part of
the house off okay got but U mainly
credit cards and we had some um student
loan Parent Plus student loans for our
kids gotcha how much in student loans uh
it was probably around 50,000 wow The
Parent PLUS Loan man you guys got out of
that alive there was home repairs home
repairs home repairs okay gotcha and a
couple car loans and cars we had to
replace okay right well well take us
through this journey let's start 60
months ago okay what caused you guys to
get on this journey okay well we
originally had attended the financial
University in 1993 okay and probably
been in and out of debt about three
times okay but we just couldn't seem to
stick with a program and so that many
months ago we found our sell paycheck to
paycheck and we called our older son
it's like can we borrow a $100 until we
get paid we just don't have it and he
was like yeah but he's like we need to
figure out what's going on with your
finances cuz you all got to get ready to
retire yeah and so uh we found out at
that time we had given both our uh Sons
the Financial Peace University is
wedding presents when they got married
but my son David and his wife ailia
actually stuck with the program they
paid off all their uh stud student loans
for vanderbelt and Butler and they don't
have any um debt at all except their
house that's all they're doing now and
they've like moved up three different
houses and just their excitement you
know we even called D my son David David
Ramsey sometimes there you go because
he's just so excited about it is this
the the sharp looking young man you keep
looking at here okay is this also the
same son that you called and ask for
$100 yes so you gifted him Financial
Peace University back in the day he did
it he did y'all didn't do it yet yeah we
didn't stick to it we didn't stick to
wow I love it but you saw the fruit he
sent us back to the class so then we did
it again and then he just helped us stay
with the baby steps and when you say
like who's our cheerleaders there they
are David way to go what a good son you
know and so we uh also had like 18
snowballs that we had to work on sure
and so Amilia knows we like cats so she
made us like a cat chart and we'd color
in a cat when it was paid off and have a
glass of wine oh very good is so cute
and then David would make progress
report for us and we didn't always do
quite as good as he wanted us to do but
I think we have found out what our
problem was uh this is the nerd and I'm
the free spirit but the discipline and
accountability is what we were lacking
and that's what they helped us find and
so now we finally have the real peace
and it's just really awesome awesome I
think you guys have an incredible family
I I think that what I'm hearing is
really something special and spectacular
that you uh would be willing to hear
from him cuz that's that's the hardest
part we call it powdered butt syndrome
it's the very the hardest part thing to
do is to hear from the person whose butt
you powdered when they were a baby sorry
sorry David we're talking about you like
you're not here I just I just love this
I think it's so great yeah no it is
actually really great so okay so that's
how it got started
so your income did not change in this
time so that means you guys just started
working with what you had what did you
do to start getting momentum where our
we did both work extra okay so we did I
don't know what you had yeah I got a
part-time job worked for about five
years I guess okay so you did make
additional money beyond the 125 okay yes
gotcha all right that's what we did so
okay let me clarify something because
you said your son came to you and said
hey you're getting ready to retire you
got to clean this up so did you retire
from your normal job and just pick up
other work how did you do it no I'm
still working I plan on to retire
finally since we're yeah he was saying
you need to get ready to re got it got
it got it we were in such a mess it's
like but Joe's been went in retired for
the last couple years and he's actually
going to be able to retire this coming
December way to go we've been working
with Kevin Wells that's one of the uh
David Ramy Finance smart investors smart
investors yes okay good and uh David
kind of turned us over to him after he
took us as far as we could so now
David's got us with the house plan to
pay the house off and being able to do
some trips and just enjoy the
retirement what would you tell people
that are listening and watching to you
right now the key to getting out of debt
is what was it for you guys well I would
say probably
um gosh I don't know what do you think
to it's the discipline and being able to
actually finally see that it's going to
make a difference and not go back cuz
that was our problem we kept going back
MH and we just had to actually use the
steps in the program right yes you know
and then we would just get off of them
or start One credit card or do something
like that you know and so we finally
don't do that so can I I that's that's
interesting so be the other times that
you tried to do the baby steps you kind
of did it your way you went over here
instead of going over there right and
that caused you to go backwards but when
you finally submitted to listen this is
the plan I'm going to walk the plan the
way the plan goes that's when it well
and David's like you got to get rid of
all the credit cards and I was like no
we got to keep one everybody I was just
stumbling all the way and it's like
Christmas we got to have credit cards
vacation and it's like no no no so all
this time we've not put anything on
credit for Christmas or vacation good
job saved and did all that so it felt
really good very good breaking the mold
breaking I I we've already covered this
but it Bears repeating cuz you keep
repeating it cat that David your son
just kept riding this process going no
no no guys no yeah it's my private day
RS are right there telling this is
exciting it's uh it's also a testament
though to you guys kind of swallowing
your pride and saying all right I'm
going to I'm going to take some
encouragement wherever we get it and in
this case it's your son definitely these
are the role models for us a so so how
does it feel what's the feeling now
house is is is coming up next you're
going to pay that off you're going
retired I mean we just really feel like
we can enjoy retirement it's just a
peace of mind and be able to travel a
little bit Yeah peace of mind and we
mostly wanted to be on here just to say
no matter where you are just start now
yeah that's right yeah that's a very
good point I didn't want to ask you how
old you are so I'll ask Joe Joe we're
not going to ask cat I'm I'm a gentleman
Joe how are you I'm 66 so it's not too
late no it's not you started at 61 if
I'm doing the math right right wow right
way to go you guys are awesome how about
that really really great what a great
family uh all right so I want to call
out again David the son is over there
with his lovely family and uh so very
cool and his wife and the kiddos
watching and cheering I love that let's
let's get this ready here we go you guys
ready to go mom and dad all right here
we go we got Joe and Cat uh and they
paid off
12274 in 60 months making 125 plus plus
plus here or there and they were hustl
let's hear your Deb free screen all
right 3 2 1 we're dead
[Music]
free is Joey cat bringing it I love it
uh he was 61 yeah when they started this
process and it's not too late they went
out and hustled and and uh how about
that son I mean is he not nominated for
Son Of The Year son of the year I don't
know who gives out that award but we're
going to we're going to nominate David
uh he was their own Dave Ramsey she said
yes and possible folks this is a
reminder it's not too late because these
baby steps work
I don't care who you are or where you're
from or how old you are they work great
great stuff all right don't move more
Ramy show coming right
[Music]
up
you're listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman Jade warshaw joins me and
our scripture of the day comes from
Proverbs 169 in their hearts humans plan
their course but the Lord establishes
their steps our quote today from the
Fantastic Legend Zig Ziggler lack of
Direction not lack of time is the
problem we all have 24-hour days all
that kind of goes with your rant about
Netflix and paying off debt I feel like
you and Zig said it that's it you were
channeling some zig I love it all right
let's go to Rob who joins us now in
Milwaukee Wisconsin Rob how can we
help all thanks for uh taking my call
hopefully you can help me out here I
think I've got a fairly straightforward
question
um my wife and our our income is
increased drastically over the last
couple of years we're finally getting
our finances in in order um that we
should have been doing a long time ago
but my question is I've got a car right
now a vehicle that I owe about 35,000 on
it's worth about 277,000 give or take
and I'm wondering if that's something
that I should just work on paying off or
if it's something that I should try to
sell and and just get some pay something
you know cash and get something that's
going to be workable do you have any
other
debt uh we've got about 6,000 on another
vehicle um that we'll have paid off by
April uh in February here we'll have we
just have some small miscellaneous debts
um a couple thousand that we'll have
paid off in February other than that
we've got um a house within about 50,000
in student loans oh 50k in student loans
okay well do you think Jade at first I
was like well if your income could make
could allow you to pay that off um I'm
wondering upside down yeah what's your
income uh total growth before uh bonuses
about 240,000 tell me about the
bonuses uh for me it'll be about 33,000
a year top of that so that's going to
take you to roughly 275 roughly a little
bit below
listen you like the
car uh yeah but I I've kind of I've kind
of grown up a little bit here and
realized that it's it's just a car so
well I like that Jade cuz I'm always for
selling the car I mean it's up to you
here's the thing what I what you don't
necessarily have to do if you like the
car I'd be like listen keep the car you
you can pay it off in two years or less
yeah exactly so it's not it's not
changing anything or if you're like I
don't like that car I'm going to take
the $10,000 hit I'm going to put some
more cash with it and I'm going to buy
another 25 or ,000 car in cash I'm not
mad at that either because your income
allows for easily allows for it um your
income allows you to be debt free in the
course over the course of this next year
so there's not none of these things are
going to make or break you yeah I
figured if I if I got rid of the car
saved up for you know 12 $15,000 car I
could probably do that
five or so months if I paid you know if
I paid the car off I could probably do
that within the next 12 months I also
have part of the equation to is uh late
summer I've also got a tuition bill of
about 177,000 for the three kids um that
I'll be peing as well so I'm factoring
that into it okay I think for I think I
think all of this stuff is feasible I'm
seeing 85 9595
$100,000 of debt give or take cuz you
said you had a couple of other little
things lying around I see I see $270,000
of income and I go to myself okay 270
can you live on 170 and can you take the
other 100 and pay off all this debt and
the answer is an overwhelming yes and
that includes the tuition by the way I
think I say it all the time and this is
not directed uh specifically at you Rob
but I I I think that when you get into
this higher dollar earning it gets tough
because people are like listen I'm
making a good income I want to be able
to live the life and I want to show it
and um it gets harder to pull back
because it's more visible when you pull
back when you sell a $35,000 car and
start driving a $122,000 one people see
that and I don't think that's really a
problem for you I feel like I feel like
you're at a place where you are ready to
make those changes and it sounds like
this higher income is relatively new
right yeah last three years or so but
our biggest problem is as the income
went up all the little Miss like you're
spending went up and exactly it's just
money flowing out the bottom that you
don't even realize yeah it's just it
gets me it can get messy and before you
know you're like oh my gosh how are we
spending so my prescription coming from
here more because you know you have to
pay off the debt but really being on a
good budget is the prescription here
because that's where you really see what
you're spending and for anybody
listening not just you Rob but a budget
is it just gives you that custom
organization for your money a budget is
not a a spending restriction plan that's
not what it is it's just a plan for your
money and so it allows you to see okay
with an income of 270,000 being able to
live on 170 is still very nice yeah and
Rob I'm gonna I'm gonna come back to
your initial question and I just think
that the fact that you don't like that
car that much you just didn't I mean
when I asked you the question Point
Blank you're kind of like eh and for
that reason because there's no emotional
attachment to it I I would sell it and
it's going to give you momentum it's
going to I think you're a guy who gets
it now I think you're sick and tired of
being sick and tired I can hear it and
for that reason I would pay it i' I'd
pay the car off sell it uh so I'm sorry
I'd sell it and you making enough money
to where you can go do what you need to
do for the second car or whatever but
that's what I would do if I were you
based on how you sound but there's no
wrong decision whether you want to pay
it off or sell it put it in the baby
steps if you're going to pay it off if
you change your mind after this call but
but the way you
sound yeah I'd probably get rid of it
and it would be like a way to go I got
that mistake out of my life it's the way
I would look at that based on how you
sound but I'm curious is that where you
are or am I projecting on you no no
that's that's correct it was it was one
of those stupid purchases that that I
shouldn't have done then I'd get rid of
it I I tell you what you know first of
all I look I've made plenty mistakes but
I get I I like getting rid of my
mistakes and trying to remove them from
my mind as much as possible that is
haunting him so you're right I think
it's like a ghost I mean he's got enough
money and he's going to knock this out
either way which let's talk about that
right quick okay you have a h you have a
car you're upside down on it right he
owes 35 it's worth 27 some people face
that and they're like hey I don't know
if I can get out of this car through
what we tell people to do there cuz we
didn't cover that I'd like you to do
that so ideally if you have some money
saved you can cover the difference
between an upside down situation meaning
in this case he's about uh he's about
$77,000 $8,000 upside down if he's got
that in in savings then when he goes to
sell the car he can put the 8,000 with
it it's a clean deal but now your
carless so you've got to make sure
you've got some money for the next car
2,000$ 3,000 $5,000 cash whatever you
can muster up now sometimes you may have
hear you may hear us say listen if you
don't have that cash to meet the
difference and between what it's worth
and what you owe on it go down to a
credit union go go get you a loan
because that's the only time we would
say to take out any form of of debt
because you're still lowering your main
amount if he let's say he didn't have
any cash if he went to the credit union
Heck if he even found a credit card that
would give him that $8,000 he's still
taking away the 27 thou $27,000 of debt
and now he only has eight right so we're
doing math here we're still going lower
he now owes $8,000 not 35,000 and we put
that 8,000 in the debt snowball so now
what was 27 is
and then you continue to work baby step
two and now the math that we did there
beforehand I told him I said if you
can't pay this car off in the next 2
years that's kind of a rule of thumb if
you can't pay it off or if it's just
grossly way more than what your income
is like we say the rule of thumb is
about 50% you don't want your vehicles
to be any more than 50% of what you earn
in a year as a household in his case
that wasn't the issue he made
$240,000 but if you're sitting in a
situation your take-home pay is
$70,000 and you have a car that's 30 and
your wife has a car that's 35 y'all are
tripping and tripping hard both of y'all
need to sell those Vehicles so that's
kind of how we do it um am I leaving
anything out so if you're selling it
private sale you're going to get the
best value for that you if you're upside
down you put the car on the market you
you write a bill of sale for it you get
your money from the the credit union put
it with the money from the sale you're
good and now you're able to send get get
the title and then you're able to send
that title to the person who sold the
car Y and again we prefer your your
local credit union to get a better rate
on that 8% uh and yeah you want a good
rate on the 8% but at the end of the day
I just you're pay it all quick I get it
you but my you said credit card and that
could be really high percentage it could
but to go from to go from still walking
away I get you're still walking away but
our preference is the other and and and
for obvious reasons there but that's a
great explanation for how you get out of
an upside down car thank you Jay that's
really helpful hey great hour thanks to
James Childs and the crew for keeping us
on the air thank you America this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
a